another post on Apartment Therapy calm
in the response section was a great
comment for Anna reader who said that
they traveled abroad when they were
younger and they stayed in other
people's homes and as a rule they had
this sort of mentality that they would
not take something with them from place
to place if it didn't fit into their
backpack and this almost became sort of
this mantra for that I'm almost they
said like a meditative practice so in
making the documentary and and now being
in the home for a few months as your
place to go for a while has your mind
shifted in terms of acquiring things or
has that mindset always been there have
you do now go into stores and look at
things in a different way like do I
really need this or has that always been
there for you I mean I think I've you
know at least in the last sort of five
or six years I've moved a lot you know
just from apartment to apartment and I
think that this sort of helped me
downsize more than anything else you
know just the process of like oh I'm
gonna have to like carry this box of
books up a flight of stairs when I move
or you know and then you know the
process of thinking that you don't have
that much and then you pack everything
into boxes and you're like wow that's
not gonna fit in my car that kind of
thing has kind of I think in that way
you know I probably own less than the
average person because of the moving
process and constantly kind of get
getting rid of things I'm whittling
things down but I mean that said I mean
you know we went to Melrose yesterday
and I bought a cute pair of boots that
it's like a thrift store and I mean it's
like I don't think that you know in
terms of downsizing I mean I I do like
things you know and I like the way that
having certain things you know makes me
feel creative are like having my space
set up in a certain way and being able
to see certain things does actually
inspire me like on an aesthetic level
and you know it helps me to I feel like
I'm expressing myself you know in my
life and so um yeah I mean it's sort of
for me I think I'm still kind of trying
to figure out that line you know of like
you know I like to have options of
things different things to wear because
that's fun for me and then at the same
time it's like either you know moving or
having to fit that into a small space
what's realistic so it's kind of an
ongoing question for me yeah I agree
with that and I would also add that to
people that we've had the opportunity to
visit have been really inspiring and how
they live their lives and you know have
encouraged me to do better in terms of
you know really determining what I need
and what I don't need several the people
we live with own pretty much nothing you
know I don't mean that we interviewed
I'm sorry some of the people we
interviewed you know there's there's
Tami and Logan and Tammy writes a blog
rowdy kids calm which is all about
downsizing and she does the hunter Adam
challenge where she doesn't know
anything she only owns 100 items or less
including toothbrush and quitting
clothes including dishes and I mean when
you think about that's nothing and and
Dee Williams we also interviewed she has
less than 300 hens that she counts in
and once it gets to 300 she has to get
rid of one and an interesting story when
I was at Seattle at a tumbleweed
workshop just that I stopped by Dee has
shown our trailer at the workshop that
she's taught and it's really awesome and
so I just offered you know a copy of it
on DVD because I thought I might you
know just sort of make it easier they're
trying to find Wi-Fi all the time to
show it and then she like looked at him
she's like I don't have her for that and
I was like oh yeah it's something as
simple as the DVD you have to think
about that when you live the kind of
life that she does and it was it
actually got me you know thinking about
it you know because I had 10 DVDs in my
back so so anyways it's nothing you know
nothing you have to nitpick about items
everybody doesn't have to live like that
per se but it if they can do that then I
can at least think about it and on a
broader sense and like I can you know
trim down what I have because I
definitely even I don't have a lot I
have more than I need you know there's
definitely a lot of things I just want
and I kind of just say you know I think
it's it's a good ongoing question to
have you know just in terms of like oh
what do I need and what do I want and it
doesn't have to
you know be super minimalist but I think
it's good for me you know kind of
preserving my quality of life to just
really be thinking about is having this
thing gonna add to my stress or is it
actually gonna add to what makes me
happy yeah it's funny I was think about
when I got to buy something like am I
gonna end up storing this because if so
I should just store it in the store you
know but it's it's got a home here for
now you know until I need it it's like
stay here
you